big o notation is used to classify
algorithms based on how fast they grow
or decline
it is very important to understand for
many types of programming
giorgio tunsin does a great job of
breaking down big o notation
in this course hey what's up everybody
and welcome to my mini series on big o
notation
in this mini series you'll learn
everything that you need to know about
big o notation and how you can use it to
improve your ability to create
efficient algorithms i'll use whiteboard
illustrations to help you visualize and
understand concepts
followed by coding tutorials that you
can follow along with to further
solidify your grasp of the concepts
we'll answer the question what is big o
notation and why is it useful
so what is big o notation big o notation
is used to analyze the efficiency of an
algorithm as its input approaches
infinity
which means that as the size of the
input to the algorithm grows
how drastically do the space or time
requirements grow with it
for example let's say that we have a
dentist and she takes 30 minutes to
treat one patient
as her line of patience increases the
time that it takes for her to treat all
of the patients will scale linearly with
the number of patients waiting in line
this is because it always takes her a
constant amount of time to treat each
individual patient which is 30 minutes
this gives us a general understanding of
how long our dentist would take to treat
10 patients
20 patients or even 100 000 patients
this is because since we know that the
dentist takes a constant amount of time
which is 30 minutes to treat each
patient
we can always calculate the time it
would take for her to treat any number
of patients by multiplying the number of
patients times 30 minutes
with this in mind we can categorize her
efficiency as being linear
or as we would say in big o terms big o
of n
where n is equal to the number of
patients
the time that it takes for her to finish
her work scales linearly
or proportionally with the number of
patients
we use this same technique to determine
the efficiency of algorithms
we can get a general idea of how a
function's time efficiency scales by
categorizing a given function's
efficiency the same way that we
categorized the dentist's efficiency
let's create an easily comprehensible
function that scales similarly to the
dentists
so this function is in the same linear
category as our dentist
let's step through it and find out why
to start
the input to our function is an array
with seven items inside of it
for each of those items we will log this
expression which multiplies one thousand
times one hundred thousand
now don't let these large numbers fool
you it will always take the same
amount of time to multiply one thousand
times one hundred thousand therefore
this line of code takes constant time
which brings me to a very important
point
when considering the efficiency of a
function these lines that take constant
time do not matter
well at least for our purposes they
don't this is because
if our array were some crazy length like
200 million
changing this expression to something
simpler like one plus one
would have a negligible effect on the
efficiency of the function as a whole
we'd still need to iterate through 200
million items in an
array in fact even if the function
looked like this
we would still ignore all of these
constants and say that this function
scales linearly or is big o of n
similarly if we think back to our
dentist example
we see that she took 30 minutes per
patient but even if she took
three hours per patient the amount of
time it takes her to see all of her
patients will still scale linearly this
can be difficult to grasp at first but
it starts to make sense over time
so in the last slide there was a lot of
talk about ignoring the constants but
what exactly is a constant
a constant is any step that doesn't
scale with the input to the function
for example the time to evaluate this
expression does not change with the
input because both 100 and 1000 are
constants
that is these values are always the same
this expression
always results in the same value and it
always takes the same amount of time or
constant time to return the same result
just like we use big o of n to describe
linear functions we also have a big o
name for constant algorithms which is
big o of one
a good way to think about it is every
line of code is actually a function
in and of itself which is actually true
for example
let's reintroduce this function so this
line of code is the reason why the
entire linear func function
is o of n because as you can see as the
size of n
increases the number of iterations that
the for loop must traverse increases as
well
but let's take this second line into
consideration let's for one second
pretend that we have a function
that contains only this line now as you
can see with this function
we pass in an array but the function
does nothing with the array
the only operation within the function
is constant because it doesn't scale
with any input
so regardless of how large of an array
is passed to this function
this line always produces the same
result and this is the only line in the
function
so therefore this entire function is of
1.
but wait in this function we have
multiple lines that are of one yet we
still prioritize the line that is o of n
and ignore the o of one operations why
is this
well this brings us to our last
important note in big o
we have a growth hierarchy which looks
something like this
now don't panic you don't need to
understand all of these just yet
so let's only pay attention to the ones
relevant to this video
of in and of one we'll learn about the
other ones in following videos for this
series
this chart shows the efficiency
categories in order from good
to bad that is to say that this first
case of one is the best case
and this last one is the worst case in
big o notation
when determining the efficiency of an
algorithm we only care about the worst
case
so that means that the worst case or the
highest order operation
trumps the operations that have better
performance
so if we add the performance of all of
these lines up like
so
all of the lines of code that are o of
one get cancelled out
because of in is the worst performing or
highest order part of the function
and this ladies and gentlemen is why we
ignore constants
because we are actually just eliminating
the non-dominant items because as a
function's input moves towards infinity
constants become less and less
significant
so to recap when evaluating an
algorithm's efficiency
we must take into consideration the
efficiency of each step within the
algorithm
we then find the highest order step or
the step that has the worst performance
and prioritize it over all of the better
performing steps
steps that are constant or that are all
of one or as good as it gets in terms of
efficiency
so we always ignore them unless the
entirety of the function is constant
or o of one and in that case we would
categorize the entire
function as constant or o of one and
that ladies and gentlemen
is your answer to what is big o notation
okay so to understand o of n squared
we're going to need to take a function
into consideration and the function will
look something like this
so what this function is doing is it's
going to take in
a number in and it's going to
iterate through this for loop starting
with the number zero
all the way up until the number in and
for every iteration of this top for loop
we're also going to loop through this uh
nested for loop and this nested for loop
is doing the exact same thing that this
for loop is doing it's iterating through
every number starting with zero up until
the number
in and within this nested for loop we're
console logging
the coordinates for a cell within a
matrix
but to make things clear instead of
illustrating a console log of the index
i and j i'm just going to draw a square
where these coordinates should be
for every iteration of this nested for
loop so if it sounds confusing
just try to bear with me i promise it'll
become clear
okay so let's say for example that we
call the square function with
the number four so that means that we're
going to iterate through this top for
loop starting with z
starting from zero and then we're going
to iterate all the way up until
i is no longer less than four once i
becomes equal to four
then we will stop the iteration and then
that's only for this top for loop for
each iteration
of this actual for loop then we're going
to loop through the entirety of this
nested for loop
and do this console log and instead of
logging the coordinates like i said
we'll draw a square where the
coordinates would be so you guys could
visualize this better so let's go ahead
and get started so for the first
iteration
i is going to equal zero and then we
move on into this nested for loop and
then
we're going to iterate through the
entirety of this nested for loop so
right now
i and j are zero so i and j are both
zero
so we're currently at the first
iteration of this for loop and the first
iteration of this for loop
and we'll draw a square and then we move
up one iteration of this for loop so
j becomes one and we'll draw another
square
and then j becomes two and we'll draw
another square and then j becomes three
and we'll draw another square and now j
is four and since j
is four that means that j is no longer
less than
n because n is four and j is 4 and n is
4
so j and n are now equal so we'll no
longer iterate through this for loop
so now we go back up to this for loop
and now
i is equal to 1. so i is equal to 1 and
j is equal to zero
so we'll draw a square and then i is
equal to one
is and j is equal to one so we'll draw a
square
and then i is equal to one and j is
equal to two so we'll draw a square
and i is equal to one and j is equal to
3 and we'll
draw a square and now back to this top
for loop again
because j and n are now equal we're back
up to this top for loop again
now i is equal to 2. so i is equal to 2
and j is equal to zero so we'll draw a
square and then i
is equal to two and j is equal to one so
we'll draw a square
and i is equal to two and j is equal to
two
so we'll draw a square and i is equal to
two
and j is equal to three so we'll draw a
square and then now j is equal to four
which is our in so we'll no longer
iterate
through this nested for loop and we move
back up to the top of this for loop
now i is equal to 3 i is equal to 3 at
this point
and j is equal to 0 again so we'll draw
a square
i is equal to 3 and j is equal to 1
so we'll draw a square j is equal to 2 j
is equal to 3
and then j is equal to 4 so we no longer
iterate
through this nested for loop and at this
point our i
is now equal to 4 and our n is also
equal to 4.
and we only iterate through this top for
loop as long as
our i is less than in but our eye is now
equal to our
in so now we stop iterating through this
top for loop and what we're left with
is this matrix here and the reason why i
said that
these are coordinates for cells within a
matrix
is because this here
is a matrix and these
are rows and these
are columns
so we can look at i as being our column
and then we can look at j as being our
row so for each iteration
0 1 2 3 of our column
we also have an iteration for our row
0 1 2 3. so coordinates being
0 and 0 were the coordinates for this
square
and then 0 and 1 were the coordinates
for this square
and 0 and 2 were the coordinates for
this square
and so on and so forth so what does all
this have to do with o of n
square well hey just one quick
interruption
if you are finding this video helpful or
it's bringing you to some type of
understanding please take the time to
like and subscribe
if we think about it this is a square
matrix that is
each side will be
of the same length and by length i mean
one
two three four this is of length four
and one two three
four and this is of length four and to
find the
area of a square
we just need to multiply the length of
one side by itself
because every side of a square is of the
same length
so if if this were a rectangle we would
multiply
the the width times the height but for a
square we can just multiply it by itself
because
the width and the height will be the
same length so to get the area
of this square
we're just going to multiply 4 times
four
four times four and that's going to
equal
the number of cells
within this matrix which also happens to
be
the number of times that we have to
perform this code which is
4 times 4 is 16 and 4 times 4
is the same thing as 4 square
so o of n square our n
is actually four
and that is why typically functions with
nested for loops
like a for loop and a for loop nested
within it like this function
is considered oven square i hope that
makes sense
okay so to understand oven cube
let's take a function into consideration
this cube function
takes in an argument in which is a
number
and it's going to iterate through this
for loop
and for every iteration of this for loop
it's going to
iterate through the entirety of this for
loop and
for every iteration of this for loop we
will need to iterate through the
entirety of this for loop
and i'm going to have to apologize ahead
of time for
my disappointing drawing skills but to
illustrate this i'm actually going to
have to draw
three-dimensional shapes which is not
something that i'm entirely good at
but anyways for now let's just ignore
this image for now let's focus on this
function so
for the top level for loop we're going
to be
iterating up until n so if we pass
the number 4
to our cube function we'll end up here
at this first for loop
and we're going to iterate starting from
zero all the way up until
n which is four so let's get started
so for our first iteration of this top
level for loop
i is going to be zero now for oven cube
we're adding an additional nested for
loop so there's no longer
just a row and a column now we have
rows
columns and we also have
this third dimension here which we'll
just call
height so we have the columns that go in
this direction
the rows that go in this direction and
the height
that go in this direction so at this
point we're working with
a three-dimensional array it's no longer
a two-dimensional array
and it's the same concept so it's not as
difficult as it seems we're going to
draw it out now
so we would start with this initial for
loop
and i is going to start off as 0 right
and we'll say that this initial for loop
is representative of
our columns so we can actually go ahead
and
write these numbers out just so you guys
can see
so we'll say that when i is 0 this
column is 0.
when i is 1 we're talking about this
column
when i is 2 we're talking about this
column
and when i is 3 we're talking about this
column
and of course once i becomes 4 we're no
longer
going to iterate through this for loop
because
i is then no longer less than n which is
four
it will be equal to four and we can say
the same thing for the rows
so we would say that row zero would be
here
row one would be here row two would be
here and row three would be here
now i apologize if this is difficult for
you to see it's
three-dimensional so it's not really
easy to draw this but i hope that you
guys can visualize what i'm trying to
say
and then the same thing for the height
the height would be represented by
this for loop here so k and that's
actually
i'm sorry i should i should actually
just name these by the letter that we're
using
in the actual function so instead of
calling this height
we'll call this k because it's
representative
this this for loop is represented is
representing k
here so we'll just call this k as well
and instead of calling this columns
we'll call it i
and instead of calling this rose
we'll call it j so for every iteration
of this for loop we're going to be
moving up this k
axis so if we were to write in
what the index is for k it's going to
kind of be hard to
to see right now but it will be 0
1 2
and 3. so let's try to draw this out
so let's do this step by step for a
little bit to get you guys
understanding what's happening so for
this first iteration of this top level
for loop
i is going to be equal to zero so that
means that
i this line we're going to be here at
the zeroth index of i
and then for this nested for loop j is
also going to be equal to zero
so j is here and we're going to be at
zero here
so we're still going to be here and for
k
as well this for loop here
this axis here we're also going to be at
0 which is here
so we're still going to be here so
instead of console logging these
coordinates
we'll just draw a square for this
coordinate so this coordinate is zero
zero and zero and zero zero
and zero so we'll just draw a square
here
and again you're going to have to excuse
my poor
square drawing prowess and since we
continue with k
until k is no longer less than n we're
going to continue to iterate through
this
for loop so to help you guys out i can
just tell i can just
write i right now is equal to zero j
right now is equal to zero and k it was
equal to zero
but we just drew the square for k at
zero
so now k is going to iterate it's going
to increment one
so k is now going to be equal to one
so when k is at one and j is at zero and
i is at zero so
i j k is at one then we're going to go
up another square and this is going to
be kind of
hard to see because i'm literally trying
to draw three dimensional
squares here and i'm just like terrible
at drawing i'll do my best
give that one more go
okay so once we do that k increments one
so
k is now two two is here and then
i and j are still zero so we're still
going to be at
j i here so we're still going to be in
this section so we'll draw
another two dimensional square
here i mean two dimensional cube
excuse me if i call cube square that's
definitely not right cube so there's
another cube
and of course k is going to increment
again so then k is going to become
three and then at three here
we'll draw another square
i mean cube sorry and at this point
k is going to increment
and then it's going to be equal to 4 and
once k is equal to 4
k is no longer less than n because
n is also 4 so now k is equal to n
so this for loop is done and now we move
up to this for loop and this for loop
will increment 1 and j will then be
equal to one
because for each iteration of this for
loop we go through the entirety of this
for loop so we've gone through the
entirety of this for loop
so now we can move up one iteration in
this for loop
and we can't move back up to this for
loop until
we iterate through everything within
this for loop so we're still
on so we're only incrementing the row
and then we're going back
into iterating k so now that j is equal
to one
i is still zero so we're still here
we're still here
because this is the column and then i is
still zero
this is i and i is still at zero and
we're still here
but j went from zero to one so now we're
here
so we're back into k and k is going to
start off as 0 again
so at i being 0 j
being 1 and k being 0 because 0
k this is k and this is 0
and we're here we'll draw a square
sorry once again i said square but yeah
we'll draw cube 10k
increments and we'll draw another cube
and then k increments and we draw
another cube
and then k increments
and we draw one more cube because
once k reaches four so yeah k okay we'll
increment one more time and it'll reach
four
and now k is uh no longer less than n
so we go back up to our j for loop and
that will increment one
so this one will now become two and
it's pretty much the same thing
throughout the entire
throughout the entire function and it's
getting hard to see
the cubes that i'm drawing here but
eventually we'll get to a point
where the entire cube
is filled in which will look something
like this
so we'll get to a point where the
entirety of this cube would be filled
with
these miniature cubes which are
just the iterations of these
for loops so once we get to that point
and the cube is completely filled in
at that point that means that we have
iterated through
the entirety of this top level for loop
and
feel free to take the time to try and
draw this out on your own
but i basically went through as much as
i could with the time that i have in
this video
but it's pretty much the same thing
until the entirety of the cube is filled
so once
all these for loops have completed
you'll be left with the cube
that looks like this and since this is a
cube that means that its height
and its length and its width
are all going to be of the same length
and that is to say that they're all
going to be in
because if you look here we went through
n
iterations of j
we went through n iterations
of i
and we went through n iterations
of k and again i'm sorry for my
poor drawing i hope that you get the
idea so if n is four
this is going to be 4 this is going to
be 4 and this is going to be 4.
and to get the volume of this cube
to get the volume the space within this
cube
since we know that all of these are
going to be the same
we only need to know one of them
and one of them to get the volume we
just
do for this case 4 cubed and 4 cubed is
64. and that will be the volume of this
cube
which just means that there are 64
of those of these
miniature cubes within this larger cube
and that's the volume so o
of n cubed our n is 4
so o
of 4 cubed which equals 64
which is the volume of this cube
which also happens to be the number of
times
we would perform this function console
log the
coordinates but in our case we just drew
the squares
and that is why this function is
o of n cubed
we must first understand what a
logarithm is
simply put a logarithm is the power that
a number needs to be raised to to get
some other number
i know that doesn't make much sense out
of context but don't worry i've got you
covered
let's take the number eight into
consideration
so we want to raise some number to some
power to get eight
in computer science unless specified
otherwise we can always assume that the
number that we want to raise to some
power is 2
so let's rewrite this so we want to
raise 2 to some power to get 8.
so this same equation can be written
like this where this 2 here is called
the base
and let's not forget that in computer
science the base is always two
so to find the answer to this we just
need to find the answer to this
with that in mind we can see that if we
raise two to the power of three we get
the number that we are looking for
eight so log base two of eight is three
so with all of that in mind let's move
on to the meaning of o
log n for this portion we will be using
a very bare
bones recursive function to visualize o
log in
but don't worry i will walk you through
every step
just stay with me so we will start with
the number in
we will use 8 so that you can easily see
how this relates to our explanation of
logarithms in the previous slide
so this variable in we will be passing
to our recursive
function that looks like this
so this function's time complexity is o
log in
let's dig deeper to find out why for now
let's just ignore this first line and
focus on what the function is actually
doing
so when we pass a number into this
function it divides
in by 2 or splits it in half and then
calls itself with the new halved or
divided number
let's visualize this using a graph
so we first call the function with the
value 8.
this 8 is then divided by 2. the
function then takes the result of the
division and passes it recursively to
itself as the new value for n
which in turn results in us going one
level deeper
we then do the same thing with our new
value for n
which is four that four is divided by
two resulting in a new in
and the function then passes our new
value for n
to a recursive call to itself again
resulting in us going one more level
deeper
we then do the same thing with our most
recent value for n
which is two we divide it by two and the
function once again recursively calls
itself
at this level we will stop as we can no
longer divide in without getting
fractions as the result
now we have arrived at the beginning of
the secret to understanding o log in
so watch closely if you look at our
graph
you will see that we've gone one two
three levels deep
if you recall from our previous slide
the log base two of eight
is three our input
in is eight and we've gone three levels
deep
you will also notice that we have to
raise 2 to the power of 3 or multiply 2
times 2 times 2 to get 8.
and since division is just the inverse
of multiplication
we can see that when we do something
like this
so that means that this function has a
time complexity of o log in
why because our n is eight and in
computer science
our base is always two and we must have
our
n three times or go three levels deep in
our recursive function to get to a point
where we can no longer reasonably have
our input
in which is another way of saying that
log base two of eight
equals three
and that ladies and gentlemen is the
secret to understanding o login time
complexity
and as a quick note this is not only
applicable to recursive functions
and if you're curious about that line of
code that we covered up earlier
all it does is make sure we stop
dividing in when n becomes one or
otherwise the function would keep
dividing
fraction after fraction until we
eventually exceed the maximum call stack
so we'll start with a very simple
function which contains only a while
loop
that assigns a new value to the variable
in for each iteration
and for this example let's imagine that
we're passing the value a
to our n for this function so that means
we'll iterate through this while loop
as long as 8 is greater than 1 and for
each iteration of this while loop
we're going to divide our n by 2
and reassign it to n so our n is going
to be halved for each iteration
so currently our n is equal to 8
because we passed in 8 as in and while n
is greater than 1
we're going to iterate so right now n is
eight
which is greater than one so we'll do
this math.floor
n divided by two for our first iteration
which would set our n equal to
eight divided by two which is four
and this math.floor all it does is it
floors the result of our division so for
example
if we have math.floor
5 divided by 2 we would get 2 here
instead of 2.5 so after this first
iteration
our n is now equal to four so
while n is greater than one we're going
to do another iteration so
four is greater than one so we're going
to do this again
and n is going to equal 4 divided by 2
which is going to equal 2. so now our
n is equal to 2 and while n is greater
than 1
we're going to do this again so n is
currently greater than one
two is greater than one so we're going
to do it again for a third iteration
so n is going to equal 2
divided by 2 which is going to equal
1. so at this point our n
is equal to 1 and we're going to go to
this condition here
again so while n is greater than one
we're going to do this but right now
n is equal to one it's no longer greater
than one so
we're not going to continue with this
while loop
so why is this function o log in
so our n is eight so that means that
this function
should be o of log
eight and if you remember from the
previous video
on o of login complexity this is just
the same thing as
o of log base 2
8 which just means
what power do we need to raise 2 by
to get 8 and if we write this out
what power do we need to raise 2 by to
get 8
we see that we need to raise 2 to the
3rd power to get 8
because 2 times 2 times 2
equals 8. so this 3 is what's important
because division is just the inverse of
multiplication
so if we need to multiply two times two
times two to get eight then we should
also be able to divide
eight by two three times to get one so
there's one
two three so that means that for this
function
when we pass in a value for n we're
always going to need to
divide this value in by two
log in times before we can get one
which is just another way of saying that
when we pass
into this function we're going to
iterate through this while loop
log in iterations before we get to the
value one
so if you see here we have one iteration
two iterations three iterations
so there's three iterations here so this
is this three
is log in iterations because again
o log in
just means o log
base 2 of 8 because
our n is 8 and log base 2 of 8
is 3 because 2 to the power of 3
equals 8 which is our n and that is why
this non-recursive function is o login
because there will be login iterations 1
2
3 before this while loop ends
i hope that makes sense
to start we should understand that in
order for binary search to work the
array that you are searching must be an
ordered array
both ascending and descending ordered
arrays will work
let's start by visualizing our array in
practice
this is much more useful as the size of
an array becomes much larger
but we will stick with an array
containing nine elements to help us
understand the concept more clearly
so let's assume that we want to check
our array to see if the value 100 exists
inside of the array
the naive solution would be to iterate
through each element of the array
checking to see if the value is equal to
100 like so
but for this method we have to iterate
through every element in the array up
until the value that we are looking for
what if we have to do this for an array
containing a thousand or a hundred
thousand or even a million elements
this is where something like binary
search can be useful so let's try this
again
so here we're still wanting to check to
see if the value 100 is in our array
but this time we'll use binary search to
figure this out
to start we need to find the midpoint of
our array which is just the element in
the middle of our array
our midpoint is here
now since our array is in ascending
order we know that anything to the right
of our midpoint will be a value that is
larger than our midpoint
and everything to the left of our
midpoint will be a value that is less
than our midpoint
so we need to figure out if this number
100 which we are searching for
is greater than or less than our
midpoint
this will tell us which side of our
array our number is on
so if we simply write out 43 is less
than 100 we can actually see that the
side of the array that our number is on
is this side
to paint a full picture let's for one
second pretend that the number we are
searching for is
2 and not 100 in this case 2 would be
less than our midpoint 43
therefore it will be on the left side
and this ladies and gentlemen
is why binary search will only work on
ordered arrays
because without the order there would be
no way to tell which side the number we
are searching for is on by comparing it
to the midpoint
now let's get back to the original
number that we were using for our
example
so now that we know that 100 will be on
the right side of our midpoint we can
completely do away with anything to the
left of the midpoint including the
midpoint
so what we're left with is this
what we've done is we've essentially cut
the array in half
to put this in perspective let's imagine
that we have an array with one million
elements and we divide it by two
in just one step we will have cut down
the number of elements that we would
need to search by five hundred thousand
elements as opposed to iterating through
all one million elements and searching
that way
and it doesn't stop here we will now do
the exact same thing with this half of
the array
let's remember that we are searching to
see if the number 100 exists within our
array
we will first need to find our midpoint
now don't be confused by the even number
of elements in this array
although there won't be an even number
of elements on each side of our midpoint
it does not actually matter because we
actually just need to split the array
approximately in half
for example to find the mid in code we
would do something like divide the
length of the array which is four
by two that resulting two we would use
as the index of our mid
so let's write out the indexes of this
array remembering that arrays are zero
based meaning that the starting index
will be zero
and if we take this resulting 2 and see
what value it points to
we see that our mid is 100 which is the
number that we are searching for
so in that case we would be done we have
found our number
but to prove that which one of these we
choose to use doesn't actually matter
let's explore what would happen if the
mid 54 were used
is the number that we were looking for
greater than or less than our mid
54 our number is greater than 54
so that means that we can get rid of the
left side
and what we're left with is an array
containing only two elements which again
is an even array so we have no way of
determining which one we should choose
as our mid
let's see what would happen if we use
124 as our mid
is 124 greater than or less than 100
it is greater than so we can ignore the
right half of this array
now we are left with an array containing
only one element so our so-called
midpoint can only be this element
and this element is the number we are
searching for so we are done here
so as you can see regardless of if you
have an odd array or an even array
as long as it is ordered the searched
for element will be found if it exists
in the array
and that ladies and gentlemen is how
binary search actually works and why it
is useful
so let's just start by creating a file
and we can call it login.js
for binary search to work the array that
we're searching must be in either
ascending or descending
order so you can't just have a randomly
ordered array and use binary search on
it
so that's just something to keep in mind
throughout the rest of this tutorial
our binary search function is going to
take in four arguments
it's going to take in an array
and the array is just going to contain
integer values which will need to be
ordered
so we will just do one through eight
we'll also need to pass in the first
index of our array to the function
we'll just call it start
and that's just going to be zero and
we'll need to take in
the last index of our array which we'll
just call end and we can get that by
getting the length of the array
and subtracting one from it the reason
we need to subtract one from the length
of the array is because
the indexes of the array are actually
zero based but the array itself
the length is actually not zero based
it's just
going to be the number of elements in
the array so the array length is going
to be eight but the last index of the
array of length eight
will be seven so that's why we subtract
the one and then last but not least
we'll need to take in a target value
which is the value that we're searching
for
and we're going to just search for eight
and then we can start building our
function
and we'll just call it binary search
and it'll take in the array start the
end
and the target
and this function is actually going to
be a recursive function so to start this
function off we need to find the middle
index of our array
so you'll notice that we're using a
built-in function math.floor here
and the reason we're using this is
because if we go to the definition
it says that it returns the greatest
integer less than or equal to its
numeric argument
which basically just means that if this
division expression within our
parentheses
within our function parentheses returns
something like 5.5
the value assigned to mid would only be
5 because we don't want to take into
consideration
anything after the decimal point because
we just want to find
an index which of course there wouldn't
be an index 5.5 so
therefore our mid would just be 5.
and the next thing we would want to do
is check to see if our midpoint is
actually the number that we're searching
for which is our target
so this would basically return true if
the mid value of our array
is actually the target that we're
looking for so we're returning true
because that means that the value that
we're searching for
exists within the array and we would be
done here and actually i just realized i
might actually be confusing you guys by
referring to our mid
and our mid value interchangeably so
this
mid here is actually
the index of our mid which what we're
trying to get we're trying to get the
index
so here we can just add index as well so
when i say our mid i'm actually
referring to the value
so we actually want to return true if
the value that's at our
mid index is equal to our target value
so if the value at our mid index is not
equal to our target
we then want to go on to check to see if
the value
at our mid index is greater than or less
than
our actual target so
and actually
this should be mid index sorry about
that
and actually we have another error here
so delete until
start and then target should be
here and
that should work
so yeah let's take the time to
understand what's happening in this line
of code here
so if the value at mid is greater than
our target then that's going to mean
that
our target is actually in the left side
of the array because if we look here
and we take into consideration
that 5 is going to be our mid in this
situation in the first
execution of this function 5 is going to
be our mid and
if 5 is greater than the number that
we're searching for
then that means number that we're
searching for is going to be in the left
side
because if five were if the number that
we were searching for were greater than
five
then it would be in the right side of
the array because
our array is in ascending order so this
is
to check to see if the item that we're
searching for is in the left side of the
array
and if it is what we're going to do is
we're going to pass in
our start which is going to remain the
same so we're going to keep the same
start
which is going to be in this case it's
going to be index zero
and then our end is going to be mid
minus one minus one because
we're going to actually do away with our
actual current mid
and actually wow this should be mid
index as well
we only need to assign the current mid
minus 1 to our in
variable because our next execution of
the function would have this
as our end and then this as our start
and therefore we'd only be searching
one two three four which we would then
in turn find the mid for one two three
four
and then we would do the same thing so
now
what would happen if the target value
that we're searching for
is greater than our mid value well let's
see
so in this particular case
the target value would be less than our
mid so that would mean that the target
value would be in
on the left side of our array but if
that were not the case then
if our target is larger than our
midpoint then we would do something like
else return
so we're still going to the function's
still going to call itself of course
but this time we're going to pass in the
ray
the the array and instead of passing in
the original start point we're going to
be passing in
the midpoint
mid index plus one and that's going to
be our new start point
and this is because we're starting from
the midpoint
to the right side of the array because
the actual value that we're looking for
is in the right side of the array and
then
at this point our end can just stay the
same because the end is just the end of
the array
so let's let's have a look at this again
so so let's again pretend that for this
execution
our mid is 5 and but this time
the actual value that we're searching
for is greater than our midpoint
so that means that it can't be on this
left side because everything on the left
of our midpoint is going to be less than
because our array is in ascending order
so
it's going to be on this right side and
if it's greater than our midpoint then
of course we don't need to take 5 into
consideration which is why
instead of doing mid index and in
instead of returning
mid index and end to the function we
only need to return mid index plus one
which is going to be this index here
it's going to be index it's going to be
this value 6
at the index one index above our actual
mid
now at this point we're only searching
our end
and our mid plus one and we're only
searching
these three elements in the array that's
what both of these
conditions cover so this first condition
covers
if the item is to the left of our mid
which is over here
and the second one covers if the item
that we're searching for is in the right
of our mid
and this is how binary search works this
is why binary search is more efficient
than say linear search because we don't
need to check
every element in the array we can
actually essentially eliminate
half of the array by knowing whether or
not the item that we're searching for is
less than or greater than
the midpoint so let's go ahead and see
if we can actually run this function
and get it to work and i'm going to tell
you right now we're going to try and run
it twice we're going to try and run it
searching for the actual
value that we know that's in the array
and we're going to try and run it
searching for
a value that's not in the array and
you'll see that we're missing something
in this function
so let's go ahead and try and run it now
to run it obviously we have to
invoke the function so we'll go binary
search and we're going to pass in array
uh start and end target
and we're going to save that
so we will try and run it by just using
node
login.js
and we broke it nice
forgot to add in the target here so
it caused the entire function to fail
let's see let's try it again
okay so let's see what happens if we
actually return the value
i mean console log the return value of
the function
and we get true because 8 is found
within the array
but
what you'll see here is if we search for
something that doesn't exist within the
array
we're going to break it again so 10 does
not exist so let's
try it again and we got maximum call
stack size exceeded because
let me show you what it means maximum
call stack size exceeded
so what we're doing is every time we
don't meet this condition
true we're going to call a binary search
again which is we're calling the
functions recursively calling itself
again
and if we're if we're searching for a
number that doesn't exist within the
array
binary search is basically going to keep
calling itself recursively and
there's never going to be a point at
which it stops even if it doesn't find
the item within the array it's still
going to continue to recursively call
itself
until eventually we reach the maximum
cost act size which is basically
you you've exceeded the amount of memory
allocated to this
particular application so to solve this
issue
what we want to do is we want to add a
base condition that will
stop the function from recursively
calling itself after
it's checked the entirety of the array
so we can do
if start is greater than
end then return false
so the reason why this works is because
if the target's not in our array it
either means that the target is larger
than the largest value in our array or
it's smaller than the smallest value in
our array so that means our function
will keep checking our array until
eventually we get to either the largest
item
if the target is larger than the largest
value in the array or it gets to the
smallest item if the target is
smaller than the smallest item in the
array and at that point the start and
the in values will be equal
and at the point where both the start
and the end values are equal
passing our start in our in to either
this line
or this line will in effect make the
start
greater than the end and now we can run
this again
using this tin that doesn't exist within
our array
and as you can see we get false
and if we even added
negative here oops
negative 10 doesn't exist so we get
false as well
and let's see
what else can we try
let's just try 2 we know 2 exists and
then
and we get true
so let's change this back to 8
to get a feel for why this function is o
log in
let's actually let's go ahead and create
a longer
array here so currently our array only
contains these eight elements and it's
going to be kind of hard to get
a general understanding of the way that
our input
scales with such a small array so we can
go ahead and uh
let's just just empty out our array
and we'll just create our own array
so let's see so trade our own array we
can just do
for let i equal
zero while i is
less than 1024
i plus plus
and then here for each iteration of i we
can just do
raid up push i and hmm let's think
let's actually make i uh one
and then we'll make this uh less than or
equal to
and then after that we can console.log
our array and for
now let's just comment this out and
let's see
okay so at this point we have a longer
array which
will hopefully help for you guys to
visualize
how the input is scaling when i do some
console log trickery here so yeah so we
don't need to log this anymore
just delete that actually so we're
creating a new array here
and it's going to be an array that has
elements from 1 to 1024
and for the purposes of this example i
don't want us to find
the element i mean the item in the array
so we're just going to change this to
something that doesn't exist within the
array so we'll just put like that 100
000 does not exist within our array and
also the
end and this is getting the end from
this current array so we're going to
need to bring this down
to after we create our full array
so this array is empty here and then
we're adding all the values in this for
loop and then we get the end of the
array
and the start of course can still be
zero because it's zero
and also we can go down here and delete
till
b we don't need to console.log this
anymore because we're going to do
another console log so we're going to
execute the function here and then here
is where we're going to try and make
some magic happen
so for each call to binary search like
each recursive call
we want to not just recursive call the
first call for the first call and each
recursive call
we want to uh log with the array
that we're searching through is looking
like so in the beginning
it's the full array which we just showed
when we console logged in earlier
and then at each call to the function
the array is going to essentially be
halved so it's going to look something
like let's see
console.log we'll do dot
slice and we're going to do the start
and the end
so what that does is it's
only going to show the parts of the race
from the start to the end it's not going
to show the full array anymore
and let's see if that works let's see
so here we can do node login okay and
yeah that worked so
maybe i can make this smaller so you can
see
so when i make it smaller like this it's
kind of easy for you to see like
well at this point the array is too long
to
show its entirety but you can still see
what's happening here so like since the
value
is greater than the left side of the
array you can see that
all these lower values are going to
essentially be
eliminated and it continues to get
halved
and halved and halved and here's where
you can start to see visually what's
happening here like you can see that
it's
the array is continuing to get smaller
and smaller
to understand o of n log n we will take
this small function into consideration
this function has a complexity of o of n
log in
let's step through this code line by
line so that we may understand what is
happening here
this function takes one argument in
which for the sake of this example will
be four
we then declare another variable y which
we will set equal to n
we will get to what this variable y is
for later
and at this point we have a while loop
that iterates through
in until n is equal to one for every
iteration through
n this code within the while loop is run
let's visualize this
for the first iteration of the while
loop n starts off as four
but we divide it by two so n is now
equal to two
then we get to this line of code which
is the start of a for loop
this is where this variable y comes in
the reason we declared this variable
before the start of the loop
is because n is getting divided by 2 for
each iteration
this in turn is reducing the size of the
variable in
but for this inner for loop we need it
to iterate through the original size of
our original in
so we stored the original in in a
separate variable
ok back to this inner for loop
for each iteration of this for loop up
until the size of in
we will log or print the value for i
once this is finished we move on to the
next iteration of the while loop and
repeat the process
going into this iteration n is now two
we start by dividing in by two so n is
now one
and once again we iterate through our
inner for loop up until the size of y
now at this point you will notice that
our in is now one
if we check the condition of our while
loop we see that we only want to iterate
while
n is greater than one so the while loop
will now terminate
and the function is finished now after
all is said and done
and with everything written out we can
see that there is a top level loop here
and there is an inner loop for each
iteration of the top level loop
so this is where the magic happens so
pay close attention
for every iteration through the top
level loop which iterates until
n is 1 n is divided by 2.
this means that this top level loop
never actually iterates through the full
size of our input
in the value for n is being split in
half for each iteration which is why we
would say that this top level loop has a
complexity of o log in
if you are confused about why this top
level loop is o log in
let's take some time to prove it by
writing it out
so this is o login let's plug in some
numbers
now if you've watched my video on o log
in you know that in computer science the
base of a logarithm is always two unless
stated otherwise
so this can be rewritten as log base two
of
four four because we are replacing in
with our actual
input for n which is 4 and
log base 2 of 4 is 2 because you need to
raise
2 to the power of 2 to get 4.
and as you can see this makes sense
because for this top level loop we only
iterate two times
so for this top level loop we have log
base two of four
equals two now we need to take a look at
what is happening in each of the two
iterations of the top level loop for
each iteration we loop through the full
size of y
which is the original size of n so that
means that each of these inner loops has
a complexity of
n which just means that processing time
increases linearly with the size of
n now this is where we bring everything
together
o of n log in really just means o of n
times log n
and if we plug in some numbers here we
get this
because remember log base 2 of 4 equals
2.
and if you look at our visualization it
makes perfect sense because for each
iteration of the top loop we iterate
through the entirety of y
which is our original value for n
and that ladies and gentlemen is how you
visualize of n log in
so we can start by creating a file let's
just call it merge sort
we'll then create a function which we'll
also call merge sort
[Music]
the argument to this function is going
to be the array that we're looking to
sort
for the first portion of this function
we'll need to make sure that the array
that we're passing in has a length
greater than one
we will need to do this because if the
array is only of length 1
and there's only one element in the
array then it is already sorted
this will also be our base case as this
merge sort function
is going to be a recursive function next
we're going to need to split our array
in half
to do this we'll first need to find the
middle index of our array
so what this math.floor here does is it
makes sure that we only take into
consideration the base number
from the result of the division so for
example if we divide
a number that results in i don't know
let's say 5.5
we wouldn't take into consideration the
number after the decimal point so we
would only
return to the variable the number five
and
this is because when taking indexes into
consideration
there is no index 5.5 or 2.2 or 1.1
there would only be an index
1 5 or 2. so this is why we're using
math.floor here
and once we have the middle index of our
inputted array we can then split the
array in half and create
a separate array for the left side and a
separate array for the right side
so we can do that by just creating
a new array left array and then we can
set
left array equal to the input
array.slice
and then the indexes are going to be the
arguments that we pass
so basically slices from and to so we
want to slice from
the first index of our input array and
we want to
slice up until the middle index that we
just
that we just got and that's because we
want the left side of the array so
let's say for example the array looked
like this
and we went we went ahead and got our
middle index which would be something
like this three here
and then we want to create an array
starting from this zeroth index
up until our middle index which would be
the left half of the array
and then we would go ahead and do the
same thing for the right half of the
array
so we're going to actually go ahead and
do the same thing for the right
half of the array we'll just call it
right array and we'll do array.slice
again
but this time we're just going to do
from the middle index all the way until
the index the
the last index of the array and the way
we get the
last index of the array is just by using
array.length
and this here can actually be a bit
confusing because we know that
array.length gives us the length of the
array which is the number of elements in
the array
and we also know that array indexes are
zero based so
basically if the length of an array is 5
there will only be
index 0 1 two three and four there won't
be an index
five so here you might be wondering how
this is actually working and it's
because
oh actually there's an error in this
method it's not slicer it's just slice
but it's because this slice method
slices up to
in but not including in so basically
this
end value it's not included in the
actual
array slice only the value before it
will be included
so for example if we have an array that
looks like
that looks like this
the end that we would use for this array
would be three even though that there's
only index zero
one and two it will slice
up until end not including end so
this is why we don't need to subtract a
1 from this because if we were to
subtract a 1 from
array.length and use that as the last
index or the end index that is passed to
the slice method then
we actually wouldn't get the full array
we would only get
up until this one but not including this
one so the array would only look like
this in the slice
i hope that makes sense it's a bit
confusing
and also keep in mind that with uh this
example i just gave above
i'm actually not taking the middle index
into consideration
so for this array in particular it would
look something like array dot slice
well slice and then it'll be zero index
up until array.length minus one
anyways last but not least for our
actual merge sort function what we're
going to need to do
is implement the recursive portion of
the function which is we're going to
return
and bear with me we're going to return a
helper function that we haven't created
yet and we're going to call it merge
and within this merge helper function
we're going to
accept two parameters which is going to
be the left array
and the right array and what we're going
to pass to merge is going to be
the recursive call to merge sort
and then our left array and we're also
going to pass in the recursive call to
merge sort
and our right array
this is going to seem a bit confusing
right now but just bear with me
i will explain how this is working and i
will try to make things clearer for you
but for now we don't actually have this
merge function
so we need to go ahead and create it so
let's go down here and create this new
helper function called
merge which will take in a left array
and right array
oh sorry and uh it's not merger it's
merge
now this function is going to be the
function that
actually merges the two arrays so the
way that merge sort works is we use a
divide and conquer approach
in which the input array is basically
halved
until we have in arrays of length one
and at that point
arrays of length one as mentioned above
when we created
this space case here an array of length
one is already sorted
so to visualize this if we have an array
that is one
there's only one element in this array
so obviously this one
is going to be the first and last
element in the array so there's
no need to sort it because there's
nothing to compare it to
with what we do in this actual merge
function
is we're going to bring these sorted
arrays together
and compare them and then sort those
individual
one element arrays so one thing to keep
in mind throughout the process of
writing this merge function is that this
merge function
is always going to take in two already
ordered arrays
starting with the ordered arrays of
length one so to start
we're going to create a variable which
is going to just be the result array
and it's going to start off as an empty
array so result
array equals just an empty array and
we're also going to define
our base indexes for the left array and
the right array
but left index equal
zero then we'll do the same thing for
right
[Music]
and next we'll create a while loop
that's going to compare the two arrays
element by element
[Music]
and actually there's a mistake here
it's just length so within this while
loop we're going to compare each element
of both arrays in whichever element is
less than the other will get added to
the result array
we'll then increment the index of
whichever element got added to the
result array because that element no
longer needs to be compared
if you're a bit confused by this just
bear with me i'll actually
create an illustration for you to
understand it better but for now let's
just write
out the code
[Music]
now let's imagine that the arrays that
we want merged look like this for the
left array
and this for the right array now keep in
mind that the merge helper function
merges ordered arrays so it will not
work on unordered arrays
in this example we are merging two
ordered arrays of length three to show
the entirety of the function's
functionality but this will also work
for naturally sorted arrays of length
one
so for this while loop to continue both
left index and right index need to be
less than the length of their
corresponding arrays
as you can see these indexes are
incremented every time that index's
element is pushed to the result array
so if we draw this out it looks
something like this
here are the two arrays and their
indexes in this next line we check to
see if the element of the left array
index which is currently zero
is less than the element at the right
array index which is also zero
so is 3 less than 1 no so that means we
do what's in our else condition which is
push the right array element at its
current index to the result array and
increment the right array index
and now our write array index is 1 so we
can move this
and then once again we do our comparison
at the top of the for loop
is 3 less than 6 yes so we push 3 onto
our result array and increment our left
array index
and we can move this over as well
and back to the top of our for loop
again
is 12 less than 6 no
so we're going to use the code in our
else condition which is push the right
array element
6 to the result array and increment the
right index
and again we will move this and now
is 12 less than 15 yes
so we push the 12 from the left array to
the result array and then increment the
left index as well as move this arrow to
the new left index
now is 16 less than 15. no
so we move on to our else condition and
push the 15 from the right array
to our result array and increment the
right index by 1.
now at this point this while loop will
terminate because if you remember this
while loop will only continue if the
left index is less than the left array's
length and the right index is less than
the right array's length
at this point our right index is equal
to the right array's length
as you've probably already noticed
there's still a 16
left in the left array that has not yet
been pushed to the result array
but the while loop is already complete
so what do we do
after the while loop we're going to add
another line of code that looks like
this
so this return is going to return a
single array that is a combination or
concatenation of three arrays
the result array a slice of the left
array and a slice of the right array
so this slice function if we only pass
one index to it
it will be used as the start of the
slice and will slice up until the end of
the array
let's break this down so if you remember
from the last slide
our result array currently looks like
this
and we're going to add to it a slice
from the left array starting from the
left index that we incremented which is
2
which results in an array containing
only this part
and we're going to add to that a slice
of the right array starting from the
right index that we incremented which is
3 which results in an empty array
because index 3 would
be here and with all of those combined
the result being returned is an ordered
array that looks like this
and now let's go ahead and add in the
return that we just discussed
in the illustration
and this completes our merge function
and now that the merge function is
complete
our merge sort function is also complete
and now we can go ahead and test this
out
to test this we will need to create an
array
and this array we will need to pass to
our merge sort function
and there you have it our sorted array
and if we take the time to go back in
here
and have a look at the code you'll see
that within this merge sort function
we're
dividing the input array in 2
recursively
which makes this merge sort portion of
the function of log in
and actually this merge function is of n
because it needs to touch
every element within both arrays to
actually sort them so with this merge
function being
open
and the actual recursive merge sort
function being of login
for every level up until the depth of
this recursive function we're actually
going to be
doing this merge which is of in so to
get the overall time complexity we would
just have to
multiply the depth of this recursive
function
by o of n which is o of n log n because
of n log n is just multiplying
in by log in and log in in this case
will be the depth at which this
recursive function
needs to traverse
so let's visualize this merge sort
function
we'll go through the code line by line
so let's imagine that we have an array
that looks like this
so this array here will be our input
array so this is the array that we're
going to pass to our merge sort function
here so this array is this array
so the first portion of the code here it
just checks to see
if our array is greater than length one
because an array of length one is
already sorted so if we get an array of
length one here
we're just going to return that array as
an already sorted array
but if the array is greater than length
one
then we're going to move on to this
portion of the code
and this portion of the code is where
the divide and conquer
approach is implemented so basically
here we're going to split our input
array
by getting the middle index of the array
we're going to split it into two
separate arrays which will look
something like this
and these individual arrays left array
in right array
after they're split they're going to be
once again passed to the merge sort
function
and once again we end up at this portion
of the code
because this array and this array
are individually being passed to this
merge sort function
so for each of these we end up at this
portion of the code
and both of these arrays are
not less than length two we have an
array of length two and we have an array
of length three
so they're going to move on to this
portion of the code in which we use the
divide and conquer approach once again
and let's go ahead and write that in
here actually because it's
important
so once again we're going to get the
middle index of our array
and create a left array and a right
array by splitting
the single array on its middle index
so you'll notice that this array this
array
and this array are already of length one
and as as we've seen here
we're going to pass these arrays of
length one to merge sort
we're going to pass these arrays in to
merge sort and then
they're going to get to this conditional
and they're less than
length 2 so we're just going to return
these arrays
so for these arrays we can stop
but this array here is of length two so
this array
is going to get to this portion of the
code again
and we're going to split it
and now these arrays are of length 1 so
we can stop here as well
so these calls to merge sort are the
same as
these calls to merge sort but we still
haven't called merge
and what merge is going to do is is it's
going to take two
already sorted arrays and it's going to
merge them together into one single
sorted array
and what that's going to look like is
going to be called here
these results are going to be merged
together into one
sorted array so these two sorted arrays
are going to be combined and returned
here
as a sorted array of length two
and the same thing will be done here
we're going to merge
and these two sorted arrays are going to
be combined
and returned here
as a single sorted array
and we'll do the same here
merge
and these two sorted arrays are going to
be combined
and returned here as a single sorted
array
and last but not least
we're going to merge here
and these two sorted arrays are going to
be combined
and returned here as a single sorted
array
and let's not forget our initial call to
merge sort
so that's how we can visualize recursive
merge sort
but you're probably still wondering what
this merge function is actually doing
so as mentioned before this merge
function takes two already sorted arrays
and it combines them together into one
sorted array
and that function looks something like
this
so as you can see merge takes in a left
array and a right array
both of which are sorted and then it
will return this result array
which is a combination of both the left
array and the right array
sorted so to understand the time
complexity of merge sort
we'll take a array and array of length 4
into consideration
so this input array will pass to the
merge sort function
and what that call to merge sort will do
is divide the array
approximately in half
and those halves will be passed to merge
sort recursively
and at this point we have our arrays of
length one
so we can't split these arrays any
further and to understand
the time complexity of merge sort we
need to understand
o log n so as we know in computer
science o log n
is the same as log base
2 in and in this case n is the length of
our array here which is four
so and the reason you need to understand
log in
is because this divide and conquer
approach that we're
implementing here is log in that is to
say that
log base 2 of 4
which is our n our n is 4
equals 2 and that's because
2 to the power of 2 equals
four which means that
for an array of length four there will
be
two levels to our recursive tree
structure
and we can see that here we have level
one
and we have level two
so this is a level and this is a level
and for each one of these levels
what we need to do is we need to touch
every element of in because we need to
sort them
and in order to sort them if you
remember from our illustration of merge
within this merge function the while
loop within this merge function
needs to touch each element to compare
the elements and create the merged array
so that means that for each level
we need to merge and this merge function
needs to touch every
element of n
so that means that each level
is actually oven
and there are log in levels so
o of n times
log n really just means
o of 4 because 4 is our
n n is
four one two three four so four is our n
times log base
two of four and as we seen here
log base two of four is actually just
two
times four so
the number of elements in the array and
the number of levels that we need to
traverse
so for every level we need to touch
in elements in the array which is
two times four and
that's why merge sort has a complexity
of
of in login
so we'll start by examining this
recursive implementation of fibonacci so
let's imagine that we pass
the number 4 to our fib function
so at this point four is our value for n
so after we call this function we'll end
up at our first if block and this
if block just returns zero if n equals
zero
and then we move on to a second if block
and the second if block
just returns 1 if n equals 1. so once we
pass the number 4 into our function
we'll end up at this first if block
and both of these if blocks are base
cases because
as we know with recursive functions we
need to have a base case so that the
function doesn't continue to call
itself even after we're finished so we
pass the four into our fib function
and four is not equal to zero so we we
don't return zero
and four is not equal to one so we don't
return one so we end up here
and what this return does is it adds
together the result of
two more calls to the fibonacci function
this first fibonacci function we're
going to call with our n
minus one so four minus one and this
second one we're going to call with our
n
minus two so four minus two so let's
have a look at what that looks like
and as we can see four minus one is just
equal to three so this would actually
just be
three and same for here this would just
be equal to two
so at this point we have two calls to
our our fibonacci function
uh one which we're passing three is our
in
and one in which we're passing two is
our in so
for both of these calls neither one of
these will
return at these if blocks so we'll end
up back down here again
which will look like this
and again we can just do the math in the
parentheses
and let me just make this a little bit
smaller so at this point for
these three calls to the fibonacci
function we're going to reach our base
case
because we're passing 0 for this call
and we're going to just return 0 at that
point
and we're passing 1 for these two calls
and we're going to just return
1 at those points so these
are going to be complete these ones are
done
and for this function we're passing 2 as
our n which isn't equal to zero and
isn't equal to one so at this point
we'll
then again go down to this portion of
the code
and now these two have reached our base
cases as well
and one more time i'll need to shrink
this
so now we'll get into the reason why
this recursive fibonacci function is an
exponential function
first let's start by observing this
recursive tree structure
so as we can see here we have one two
and three levels to this recursive tree
structure so we can write that out
level one level two
and level three and for this first level
here
we're calling the fib function two times
so one
two and for this second level we call
our fib function
four times one two three
four so this level we make two calls to
the fibonacci function in this level we
make four calls to the fibonacci
function
and let's just ignore this third level
for now and let's just focus on these
top two levels so two here is the same
as
two to the power of one and four here is
the same as
two to the power of two and as you can
see our exponents
correlate with our levels so actually if
these three functions were to make their
two additional calls to recursive
fibonacci we would have
something that looks like this so we
have two calls here
two calls here and two calls here so
we'll just
write this out
so let's imagine that these are also
additional calls to the recursive
fibonacci function and let's just
imagine that that's the case for one
second just so that we can get a better
understanding of why this function
is of exponential time complexity so now
if we count the calls
at this third level to our recursive
fibonacci function
and keep in mind that these calls won't
actually be made
only these ones will be made but we're
just writing this out so that we can get
a better visualization of what's
happening here
so if we counted out these calls to the
fibonacci function
it would be 1 2 three four
five six seven eight so we would have
eight calls at this third level and
eight is the same as
two cubed or two to the power of three
and as you see
once again our exponent corresponds with
our level
so that means that if our n is 4 we
would go
three levels deep and at each level the
number of calls to our fibonacci
function
increases exponentially but you might be
wondering
since our n is 4 and we stop
here when it's 2 to the power of 3 as
opposed to 2 to the power of 4 how does
that result in this function being
o of 2 to the n well it's actually quite
simple so
in actuality this fibonacci function is
o of 2 to the n minus 1.
and if we write this out you can see
it's o of
2 to the fourth power minus 1
which is just equal to o of
2 to the third power which is the same
as the number of calls made at this
third level right
and if you remember in big o we ignore
constants so if in actuality this
function is
o of 2 to the nth power minus 1
and we ignore the constants that means
that we're going to ignore this minus 1
which results in the time complexity of
this function being
o of 2 to the n and at this point you're
probably wondering
how we're able to add these function
calls in here and
in actuality i only added these function
calls in here to give you guys a better
visualization of what's happening
at each level and why we're considering
this function to be
o of 2 to the nth power because it's
easier to visualize
if we actually write out these functions
that we're actually not calling
and we can do that because with big o as
we've learned
we're only looking for an upper bound
like we're not looking for a tight bound
we're not looking to be very specific
we're only looking for you can say an
estimation of the worst case scenario so
as you can see here on this left
function we're
calling fib and then we're subtracting 1
from n
and on this right one we're calling fib
and then we're subtracting two from in
so this right side of the tree is always
going to be shorter than this left side
of the tree there's always going to be
this empty space
because on this right side of the tree
at every level we're subtracting two
and at this left side of the tree at
every level we're subtracting one
but when we're taking big o into
consideration we don't need to worry
about this
and regardless of what number we pass
into this function at the bottom most
level there's always going to be a gap
on this right side but that's okay
because we're only looking for an upper
bound
so these are just here to help you
visualize what is actually happening
and why this function is considered to
be of exponential growth and that is why
recursive fibonacci is of exponential
time complexity
i hope that makes sense
we'll start with the function that we'll
call f and this function
will be a recursive function so this
first portion of the code is going to be
our base case
so if the value for n passed to this
function
is equal to zero then we're going to
print these stars
and then we're just going to return but
if we pass a value to n
that's not equal to zero then we will go
down here to this for loop
so let's start with an example so let's
say that we pass
the number 3 to our function what will
happen first is
we'll check to see if n which is 3 in
our case
is equal to 0 which it's not and then
we'll move on to this for loop
and what this for loop is going to do is
for every iteration
of in for every iteration up until 3
from 0 up until 3 which is our in
we're going to recursively call this
function again
this time using our n minus 1. so let's
let's try to visualize this so if we
pass 3 to this function
and we end up at this for loop we can
write it out like this
so for each index
up until three but not including three
zero one two and the reason
we're only doing for each index 0 1 2 is
because
here i starts off as 0 and we're going
to
iterate through our input value in
up until i is no longer less than n
so once i becomes equal to n then we'll
stop so if i were to be 3
then we wouldn't go through this loop
again
so that's why it's 0 1 2.
and for each of these iterations 0
1 2 we're going to call this function
again
and that's going to look something like
this
so if you look here we're subtracting a
1 from n
that we're passing to the function at
each iteration of this for loop
so if n is 3 here
for each of these n is going to be equal
to 2
because we're going to subtract a 1 for
each of these
so these are actually going to be f2
and for each of these we're going to do
the same thing
that we did for the first call to this
function
to this f function
but this time we'll only iterate through
indexes
0 and 1.
so each of these are their own
individual
calls to this recursive function right
and each of these
need to have their own for loop which is
this
this and this so at this point
f is two so we're iterating up until
i is no longer less than two so we'll
have
index zero and one that we're iterating
through and for index zero
and one we're going to do this and the
same for this
call to the recursive function for index
0 and 1
we're going to do this and the same for
this one and i apologize if the writing
here is getting too small but you'll see
that this recursive tree gets
very large very quickly so i'll actually
need to shrink this down a little bit
so that we can have more room so for
each of these
we're going to call the recursive
function again
but this time the function is being
called with 2
minus 1 which is going to mean
that our n is going to be 1.
and let's make this a little bit smaller
actually and again
i apologize so at this point
our four each is only going to happen
once for index zero
oh man this is getting really tiny
okay so at this point our f is one for
all of these calls
to the recursive function and i starts
off as zero
and as long as i is less than n which is
one
then we'll do this code and it's only
going to be less than n when it's zero
which is this one iteration
so for each of these calls to the
recursive function
we're only going to call this function
once
for this first iteration which is
and zero this point it's going to be f
one minus one
and f1 minus one is actually going to be
equal to zero so it's going to be
f zero
so we're going to be passing zero as our
in to the function
and it's going to be a little bit
difficult to see because it's small but
if we remember up here in the actual
function our base case is if n is equal
to zero
then we're just going to console.log and
then we're going to return
so for each one of these calls to the
recursive function
we're going to perform this code this
console log code
and then after we perform this
console.log code we're going to return
so it's going to be finished this entire
function will be finished because all of
these are going to return
they're going to log the code and then
they're going to return
and once all of these return this entire
function
is going to be complete it's going to
terminate so instead of writing out
console log we'll just
write that each of these functions
performs log
and after the log the function will
return
so it'll stop
so for the last time i'm going to need
to make this a little bit smaller
all right so what we're left with when
this function is finished
is we're left with this tree structure
and
this tree structure shows how many
recursive calls that we
had to make to get to our base case for
each of these recursive calls
and if you look here i'll go ahead and
circle these so that you can see them
more clearly if you look here for
each of these recursive calls to the
function
we had to perform this code we had to
perform this code here
for each of these recursive calls to the
function
so at the final level where our base
case was
we had to perform this code and if you
count these
you'll see that this is one two three
four
five six so six
times we needed to perform this code
passing three into our function caused
us to need to recall this
final recursive call to our function six
times
and perform this code six times and that
number six
is our key to understanding uh factorial
time complexity because if you look
here we have o of 3
factorial and the reason why is because
our n is 3 right
so it's we're just substituting so of 3
factorial right
and 3 factorial is 6
actually because to get the factorial of
a number you just multiply
every number up until that number
and if we multiply 2 times 1 we get 2
and if we multiply that 2 times three
we get six and and again we needed to
execute this console log this code we
needed to execute
one two three four
five six times and if we dig a little
deeper we'll see that
3 factorial is a result of multiplying
every number
up until 3 which is also the same as
multiplying
every number from 3 down until 1
which we can see if we look at how in
progresses
through our tree structure here we can
see that
first three is passed so first three is
passed
and then three times two is passed
three times so times
3 times 2 is passed and the result of 3
times 2
is 6 and 6 times 6
times 1 is passed so 6 times 1
2 3 4 5 six times one is passed
so this for loop first passes two
three times so passes two
three times one two three which is the
same as
three three three
times times two three times one
two three passing two and
when we pass two to the function we do
two iterations so three times two
iterations
so we're going to do this we're going to
iterate through this for loop
of two iterations three times three
times two and then three times
two is going to be six because we do two
iterations for each of these three
so this these iterations plus
these iterations plus these iterations
equals six iterations and for each of
these six iterations
we're going to pass one to the function
so six
iterations so six times we'll pass one
to the function
so that's here six times one
six times one and that is factorial time
complexity
i hope that makes sense
so to understand space complexity we'll
take this function into consideration
and this is a recursive function that
basically just returns a call to itself
with its input in
minus one and it's going to do this
until we reach a base case where n
equals zero and then it's going to just
return and at that point this function
will be complete so let's go ahead and
draw what the execution of this function
would look like
so let's say that we pass the number 5
to this countdown function
so with this first call to countdown
with our argument five
we'll end up at this base case and we'll
see that
our n5 is not equal to zero so we'll
move on to this part of the code
which is just calling this function
again with five minus one
and of course five minus one is going to
be four and once again we'll end up here
and we'll call the function again with
four minus one
and we'll continue to do this until we
pass a zero as our into the function
and i will need to make this a little
bit smaller
and finally we get to the call where
we're passing 0
as our n to the function
at this point if n is equal to 0 the
function will just return
so to understand space complexity it's
actually quite simple
so since this is a recursive function
each one of these calls
exists on the call stack simultaneously
so that means that if we call our
countdown function with 5
it's going to then call itself with 4
and at this point this initial call
still exists on the call stack and the
same for when we call
three these two calls still exist on the
call stack
and all the way down until we reach our
base case every single one of these
calls still exists on the call stack
and each one of these calls takes up
memory
so each one of these calls existing on
the stack they take up memory
and this is how we come to an
understanding of space complexity
using this recursive function as an
example because if we're returning at
this point when we reach our base case
that means that that means that we have
one two
three four five five calls taking up
space on our call stack
and five also happens to be our value
for n
so that would mean that this function
its space complexity
is o of n
so this function has a space complexity
of of n
so the most important thing to remember
here is that all of these recursive
calls
exist on the call stack simultaneously
and each one of them
takes up memory which is why if we have
if we pass in five as our in we'll have
five
calls existing in memory simultaneously
which means that our space complexity is
going to be of in it's going to scale
linearly with the size of the input so
if we increase the size of this input
the space required to execute this
function is going to scale
proportionally
with the size of this input so now that
we have an understanding
of space complexity we can get into some
common mistakes that people make
with big o
and the first one being that when you
first start out with big o
you might see a function that looks like
this that has
two for loops and you might
instinctively assume that this function
is of of n square time complexity
because you see that there are two for
loops here so that must mean the
observing square
but actually as we've learned oven
square actually means that for each
iteration
up until the size of our input we're
going to iterate all the way through
an additional for loop up until the size
of our input so what does it mean if we
have
two for loops that aren't nested that
aren't all of in square
it's actually quite simple so we have
one for loop here and we have another
for loop here
and as we already know this for loop
would be
of in time complexity and this one
would also be of in so at this point we
have two
ovens so that could easily be translated
to
o of two in which is just
o of two times n so two times we have o
of n
but if we remember from our previous
lessons we ignore constants and in this
case multiplying in by two
two is just a constant so we can
actually just drop this constant
in which case this just becomes of n
but there's one important thing that we
need to recognize here this is all in
because
we're iterating through the same input
for both of these for loops
so as long as our loops are acting on
the same input then this would be
the resulting complexity but there's
actually another common mistake that
people make when taking
time complexity into consideration which
is somewhat related to this mistake
and this common mistake involves having
two separate
inputs to the function
so let's first take this two inputs add
function into consideration
so if you remember from our last example
we only had an input we only had one
input which was a
and the two for loops looped through
that same input
but for this one you can see that we
have two separate inputs here
so we have an input a which is looped
through in this top for loop
and we have an input b which is looped
through in this second for loop
and some people might make the mistake
of thinking that this
is the same as the last situation where
the result would be o
of 2n but this is actually wrong
because in this particular situation we
have no way of knowing
the difference in size of both of these
inputs like all we know is that these
are two separate inputs
so these two separate inputs could be of
either completely different sizes or
they could be
of the same size but from our analysis
perspective we have no idea so in this
situation when we have two inputs and we
have a separate for loop for each input
we're going to
need to keep track of both of the inputs
so in this case the time that it would
take to
loop through both of these for loops is
o of a plus b
because we need to first loop through
this one up until
we reach the value of a and then we need
to loop through this one up until we
reach the value of v
of b and at this point this can't be
simplified any further we need to
acknowledge the fact that both of these
inputs are separate inputs so this would
be
o of a plus b and here we have a similar
situation where we have two
inputs but this time the for loops are
nested and
a lot of people make the mistake of
saying that this a function that looks
like this
is o of n squared but that would
actually be wrong as well
because what does solving square mean of
n squared means that for every iteration
of one
input we're going to iterate through
that same exact
input but in this situation when we have
a we have two separate inputs for every
iteration
of one of the inputs we're going to
iterate through the other input
so what that means is this is wrong in
actuality
it's o of a
times b because again we need to specify
that these are two different
inputs and these inputs could be of
different sizes
and we need to make that visible when we
take
our complexity into consideration so
that is space complexity
and some common mistakes that people
make with big-o notation
i hope that that makes sense
you